what spare body work infinitive and
today we will be doing famous trick
shots with us here we've got finished
tennis pro cost available thank you for
having me
let's do some fun tricks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's see how well the
function of the guys can return my
service first serve now I'm ready
what no chance
[Music]
I wonder if you can do a cartwheel shop
in tennis
[Music]
[Applause]
I got it barn let's go upstairs
[Music]
the upstairs winner okay I'm pretty
confident that I'll do a bit better than
a no nice one one touched it not an ace
okay that was difficult
[Music]
[Applause]
what was that okay let's see if a side
change is possible in sense in this case
the rules don't matter
[Music]
nice I'm gonna mesh the ball
out-out
I just good try
[Music]
I'm not gonna write for this
[Music]
let's see if I can do the double
[Music]
okay now let's see how well author can
receive my subs
[Applause]
[Music]
no he didn't really seem to have any
trouble with that one alright thanks for
coming over ortho and we wish you the
best of luck for Wimbley done thank you
I hope to use some tricks are there
remnants here subscribe watch our
previous videos there until next time